Jordan Klein nous explique sur quoi
exactement
voilà on verra
dans un instant on est en train de c'est
un peu comme la réforme des retraites
rien est simple en fait on pense qu'on
va avoir un sujet et finalement il
arrive parce que c'est une bonne augure
ou pas Jordan Klein
c'est ce qu'on appelle le 49 je crois
Laurent Alexandre si j'avais du courage
mais je n'en ai pas beaucoup je
commencerai par parler ce soir par ce
matin de chapitre c'est beaucoup plus
important les retraites c'est beaucoup
plus important que tout chat Jippy fort
la nouvelle version est sortie hier ou
avant-hier elle a mis 10 secondes 10
secondes pour résoudre
le problème de politique 10 secondes
c'est la nouvelle version
je suis papa flagrant
et voilà le travail s'il y en a qui
veulent venir se mesure à moi qui y
viennent et hop en voiture oui ce pays
aide les gens qui ne travaillent pas
tout qui va me dire ça
pardonctions
de synthèse ça c'est possible mais je
pense que le pignon va préférer Pascal
Praud un avatar créé par gpt4 mais
l'opinion peut-être mais ce qui
investissent si par exemple nous si nous
sommes remplacés par des avatars et que
ça coûte moins cher et qu'on dit autant
de choses intéressantes et intelligentes
comme on dit le matin je ne crois pas au
remplacement des des journalistes
leaders charismatiques en revanche je
pense que les journalistes médiocres
doivent se reconvertir d'urgence
on voulait vous parler aussi des chiens
vous aimez les chiens
aux États-Unis ça fait 31 ans que le
chien préféré des américains c'était le
Labrador Retriever et bien désormais
c'est lui le petit bouledogue français
qui vient de détrôner donc le labrador
votre ça peut vous arriver à
divertissement intelligent fait par des
gens qui eux ne le sont pas voilà c'est
la maxime de l'émission Ça va Charlotte
tu sors de réussir à faire un programme
intelligent avec des gens débiles ou
c'est une véritable performance
de respiration
très gênants
là c'est pas une image humoristique mais
par exemple on lui demande on voit des
ballons de baudruche qui sont reliés au
sol par des ficelles et on lui demande
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si je coupe
les ficelles et elle va répondre bah les
ballons vont s'envoler c'est à dire
qu'elle va merci mais non mais non mais
parce que est-ce que vous êtes mais
parce que vous êtes un humain mais vous
vous rendez compte la capacité de la
mais non mais enfin alors je me suis mal
exprimé
529 dollars pour la gagnante vous avez
vu comment on fait gagner un bébé elle
montre son smartphone
dans quelques années proches nous serons
tous sur notre canapé avec le revenu
universel pendant que je dis fera le
travail bien à vous alors vous voyez moi
ma question de regarder en arrière vous
avez prouvé vous avez peur peur du grand
bouleverseur du changement
qui arrive vous m'avez fait rire tout à
l'heure voilà vous avez la trouille
madame une image impressionnante
regardez il n'y a pas eu de blessé
heureusement ça s'est passé à Tignes
lors d'un festival de glisse c'était
hier deux avalanches regardez ce sont
déclenchés coup sur coup à quelques
secondes d'intervalle ce qui est
évidemment suscité la frayeur de tous
les participants les skieurs qui étaient
présents le directeur du Service des
pistes précises que personne n'a été
directement menacé un patron une vie un
moment très fort face à la
professionnelle lui qui se considère
comme un amateur de la communication on
étudie vos mimiques élisent
au patron pour 500 euros de l'heure
quand même moi ça m'a je trouve ça assez
étrange et après ce que je trouve
intéressant bah oui
faut se lancer
comment vous faites vous pour vous
mettre dans la podcast ou dans la peau
d'Elise Lucet justement quand vous
faites le training de l'interview alors
il peut nous arriver de simuler un
studio avec vos mimiques vos façons de
travailler donc ça c'est la forme donc
on étudie comment vous fonctionnez comme
un coach et le ferait pour un sportif
regardez si elle m'attaque de ma main
droite je la repousse et en tournant mon
corps comme ceci je la pousse vers le
bas cela s'appelle le geste pong
ce deuxième mouvement s'appelle la prise
loup là au contraire quand mon
adversaire m'attaque j'utilise sa force
pour le tirer vers le sol
comme ça
et vous répétez
il y a une notion de déséquilibre vous
êtes la professionnelle eux ils sont
amateurs
de la connaissance de l'entreprise il
l'a beaucoup plus que nous quand vous
dites qu'il y a un déséquilibre c'est
plutôt dans l'autre sens non non
l'exercice du patron qui se fait
interviewer par vous c'est que c'est un
moment très fort pour lui
séquence rocambolesque dans un tribunal
aux États-Unis l'homme en chemise bleu
comparait pour double meurtres et comme
le veut la loi dans l'origon les
policiers qui l'escortent lui enlèvent
ces menottes le suspect 3 alors la fuite
et sa tentative d'évasion et filmée par
les caméras de surveillance
[Musique]
le fuyard réussit à s'échapper il sera
arrêté des heures plus tard et remis en
détention
Seigneur Jésus pendant
mes patins louer
comme moi ne pas te louer
er
il faut estimation veut un monde
meilleur il faut s'y mettre un dans une
heure ou deux à plusieurs